Alyce's lost poems I think frustrated by
the fact that I cannot lose scraps of
poems still in the making before they
are finished and so on I decided to take
my revenge and just write compensate
myself by writing a poem to my lost
poems I think sometimes of poems I have
lost maybe they're lost it was that
saved the world still they do get lost
and I recall them only when a fragment
levitates behind discarded invoices the
blackened notice of a last goodbye a
birth a wedding invitation and other
milestones of a lesser kind the moment
torments why beyond an instance passion
dubious flash Satori in a bar taxi or
restaurant an airport waiting lounge
that births this scribble on a stained
napkin or cast of the ephemeral once
resonates then spurns the mind the
morning after all that survives mimics
her wrinkled petal pressed between pages
of long discarded books a falling leaf
trapped briefly by the passing Sun it
flashes a mere shard of memory but
filled with wistful accusations of
abandonment too late no life to it the
book is closed the moments exaltation or
despair drowned in wine rivers shriveled
in sons of Greater wars I turned these
scrapbooks of a moment's truth to
cinders there curling's curse in smoke
one small fugitive beyond recall of
usurpers summons by the morning after I
think of voices I have lost and touches
the fleeting brush of eyes that borrows
deep within the heart of need the pledge
unspoken the more than acts of faith
that forge an instant world in silent
pact with strangers
deeper deeper bonds and the dearest
loves embrace
you